yeah
good I'm great I'm here celebrating
season 2 a big little lies with you my
son is dead and I want answers
why can't you answer yes but you left
some things out didn't you
Nicole was just talking again about how
she sent the message to you you said yes
what was it that she said that got you
to sign on do you want to be in big
little life you didn't even read the
script had you never had you ever done
that before signed on without looking at
the script no but I believe in these
girls and and in that first season just
blew me away with it every everything
about it it's the writing the depth of
the performances the style the music and
I couldn't wait to see where it was
gonna go well you go toe to toe with
Rhys right off the bat what was it like
to do those scenes with her she threw an
ice cream cone at you Laurel did the ice
cream cone hurt did she get you on the
first try she just told me that's not in
the meet it's not in the show it's on
the DVD extra you got to get that scene
well everybody was talking about
honestly how nervous they were to meet
you they calling you the Queen the
legend how do you approach it when
people come up to you and are just in
obvious when I forget my lines they go
I don't know I feel so lucky and so old
you know - so I've been around and I
think that's that's part of it they've
grown up looking at my movies so I just
made me feel great the boys who play
your your grandchildren told me that
their mom took them home and they
watched all your movies so they could be
educated before they did see all the
children in their just smart
good-natured and this cast is so fun did
you get to unwind with these amazing
ladies have a glass of wine after a hard
day and have some fun on set ah glass a
glass three ani glasses Meryl oh you
learned if his infidelity just ten
seconds before he died
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]